what about someone who's retired
that you think could still just pick up
the shoes and just just jump right into
the league and just
shake [ __ ] up that's a good question i
would have to say
because i said retired right retired yep
not playing or even maybe even jennings
retired i mean jenny jennings should be
in the nba
he played eight years and he was good
with the bucks you know he got
he got the little injury but then he
came out i think he should be
obviously jerry smith's not retired you
should be in the nba um let me
give you a better one i would have to
say uh
you know what give baron davis like be
ditty
two months and i feel like he could play
in that b yo it's crazy you mentioned
brandon jennings cause i feel like he's
one of those players that i always think
like what if
i think about that with him i think
about uh oj mayo yeah
oj mayo was fire like there's like a few
of those guys uh what with ty
lawson you know what i'm saying like
guys who are in the league that like
just some [ __ ] happen or injury or off
the court [ __ ] and it's like
they were so good like brandon jens is
doing his thing now you know he has
tough crowd
i didn't i have no idea what's going on
brandon big time clothing company
uh one of the most popular up-and-coming
clothing companies and
yeah he's doing his thing